maintenant j'espère qu'à l'intérieur des
communautés autochtones eux mêmes ils
vont pouvoir voir que le bien vouloir du
fédéral et de toutes les provinces et là
que nous sommes là pour être partenaire
mais nous ne pouvons pas continuer d'y
être si ces barricades reste en place on
est au 17e jour de la crise ferroviaire
au pays je vous rappelle que le blocage
à saint lambert a été levé au cours des
dernières heures mais les autres
manifestants sont toujours sur place que
ce soit tout près de belleville en
ontario en gaspésie est également donc
je sais trudeau a été très clair hier
les barricades doivent être levés on va
regarder avec françois doury ex policier
de la sûreté du québec
comment on peut s'y prendre bonjour
françois bon jour alors on entendu je
t'ai trudeau dire c'est aux provinces à
déterminer là si elle donne le feu vert
à leur policiers est ce que c'est un
appel à une intervention policière
on souhaite depuis plusieurs jours voire
plusieurs semaines la part du
gouvernement fédéral de passer la balle
au provincial parce que oui dans des
zones provinciales
il ya des blocages on le voit des naga
belleville en ontario au québec
gaouaoui les stryges cd territoire
québécois évidemment la problématique il
faut il faut vraiment différencier ce
qui s'est passé à saint lambert des
autres sites où il ya des blocages
devront complètement différent
aucun premier aucune personne des
premières nations se trouve à saint
lambert
on n'était pas en territoire
intact un autochtone non plus alors oui
la police fait ce qu'elle avait à faire
les résultats que l'on connaît oui pour
le reste de l'opération c'est super bien
ça pour être immensément plus compliqué
ça demanderait on en a parlé cette
semaine ça demanderait l'implication de
milliers de policiers de millions de
dollars de la part du gouvernement pour
justement à assumer les frais d'un
travail coordonné entre les services de
police qui soit dit en passant se
parlent loupé la grc la sûreté du québec
dans l'ouest dans l'est les policiers se
parle on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec
une situation ou d'une province à
l'autre extrémité il ya des blocages le
pôle la confédération dans des sacs au
dos et britanniques le trafic
ferroviaire est bloqué si une opération
policière devrait avoir lieu pour
débloquer ces endroits là encore une
fois c'est une opération coordonnée qui
comporte des risques
j'en parlais avec des membres de la
première nation wire ce matin qui ont
par là qu'ils ont entendu s'être d'eau
parler du fait que la responsabilité
incombait aux premières nations brenon
et également aux provinces disent c'est
pas responsable et sam on note
inquiétudes nous qui avons vécu la crise
d'oka nous avons véhiculé crise d'oka je
suis d'accord avec vous est il vraiment
des noms qu'il faut mentionner pour que
nos boxeurs se répète
évidemment les recommandations du
coroner dans le
la situation qu'a éclair nécessité
urgence les assises légale même si
répare on les a il ya des gens qui ont
perdu la vie ça c'est pour justifier une
intervention je lis une intervention
assise légale est ce qu'on est là avec
les gens créent avec les injonctions
n'étant pas juriste je vous dirais que
je n'ai pas la certitude mais je crois
qu'avec les injonctions pu le faire il
est clair que le gouvernement futile
provincial futile fédéral ne peut
ordonner à ses policiers d'aller sur
place pour démanteler les barricades
ça c'est sûr c'est une intervention
policière oui peut y avoir des
discussions que les différents paliers
de gouvernement mais l'intervention
série policière encore une fois
coordonné entre les provinces
on ne veut pas répéter les erreurs du
passé elles portent des noms mais recèle
le mais l'autre le mot racaille brown
qui était depuis lors d'une intervention
on ne veut pas répéter ses interventions
dix septième jour on sent la pression
monter est ce que ça peut dégénérer
ça pourrait dégénérer et des deux côtés
si on dit que des gens des premières
nations craint une intervention
policière
je peux le comprendre à la suite de la
demande du premier ministre fédéral par
contre on peut craindre aussi une
intervention des gens déjà la population
civile qui sont un peu fatigués de voir
ce qui s'est passé à edmonton y ait des
gens qui ont démantelé une barricade de
façon paisible ça s'est bien passé
ce n'est pas une garantie que ça se
passe comme ça partout au canada
si des civils s'en mêle et on peut
comprendre leur fatigue en tout
comprendre leur leur à leurs attentes
alors on fait quoi en terminant en
quelques secondes avez vous une session
il faut il faut ouvrir un contact est
vraiment avoir un contact on comprend
que dans les premières nations et
plusieurs types de gouvernement mode de
gouvernement rien fait mais il faut
garder le contact on ne peut pas fermer
pas assez de remercier mes devoirs je
vous en prie cible